the fake news media breathlessly
reported over the weekend that the Trump
administration has banned the Center for
Disease Control and Prevention from
using the words fetus transgender
vulnerable science-based entitlement
diversity and evidence-based the story
predictably is not true but it should be
true because that is the essential Trump
project we will analyze the left's
insidious abuse of language then at
leisure crafts and Amanda press
DiGiacomo joined the panel of deplorable
x' to discuss how expensive it would be
to legalize these so-called dreamers has
that for euphemistic language Pope
Francis's condemnation of fake news and
speaking of fake news Al Franken's
possible unrest Ignatian I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show I have not slept in about 17 days I
am coming in from a flight last night I
had a red-eye on Thursday and then I had
a red-eye last night so I got in at
about 1:00 a.m. and I'm just I it's so
nice the two things are so nice
President Trump his administration and
the news media because just when you
think oh god what kind of show are we
gonna have today I haven't been paying
great attention to the news last day or
so you get a big whopper like this this
CDC story is the essential donald trump
project but before we can get to that
and there is a lot to analyze with then
we have to talk about safety we got to
talk about your neighborhood we have to
talk about 21st century technology and
thank our sponsors over at ring so rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you know ring because they came out with
a video doorbell that all of the cool
guys got right away and then you thought
of what is that oh you can see there's a
little video doorbell and you can see
who's at your door from anywhere so you
can be in the studio you can be at work
you can be on vacation sitting at the
beach and it'll pop up on your phone and
you can talk to them you can see when
someone's trying to break into your
house to see you doctor delivery man you
know you see what's actually happening
and they know that home security begins
at the front door but it doesn't end
there so now they're extending that same
level of security to the rest of your
home with the ring
floodlight camera so it's just like the
doorbell the doorbell allows you to see
who is there and you know whether you
want to go let them in or not the
floodlight cam is a motion-activated
camera and floodlight that connects
right to your phone with HD video and to
wait audio and lets you know the moment
anyone steps onto your property now for
some of my listeners is gonna help you
secure your home and make sure that no
one breaks in and for some of my
listeners it's gonna scare you away
because you know when you go to try to
break into someone's house that light is
gonna come on they're gonna see you even
if you take the floodlight camera even
if you take the ring doorbell it is all
uploaded to the cloud so they're gonna
get you this is really amazing in the
old days they used to have neighborhood
watches and they said more burglaries -
and and this is just 21st century
technology so they did a little
experiment ring in Los Angeles and I'm
not great neighborhood of LA ring gave
out a bunch of its project product and
within six months they noticed a 55%
reduction in home burglaries I think
that's the number that is pretty amazing
so you can see and speak to visitors
even set off an alarm right from your
phone with the floodlight camera with
the doorbell when things go bump in the
night you'll immediately know what it is
whether you're home or away it lets you
keep an eye on your home from anywhere
it's the ultimate in home security
seriously this is the 21st century it is
unbelievable how affordable this
technology is this would have been
unheard of even just a few years ago go
out and get it it is a really really
cool product and you can save up to $150
off of a ring home security kit right
now when you go to ring.com slash Noles
that's KO wles just like beyonce
ring.com slash Knowles what is it that
is ring comm / Knowles
okay we have got to get into this CDC
thing because this is what PC is all
about and it's largely why Donald Trump
was elected president The Washington
Post ran a fake story over the weekend
which is not exactly manned by its dog
is it but the headline goes like this
CDC gets list of forbidden words fetus
transgender diversity that is fake news
that headline is not true no words have
been banned for
used by the Trump administration but
that makes sense when the Washington
Post runs a headline assume the opposite
is true now at most there is some kernel
of truth here at most agencies like the
CDC had been directed to avoid a certain
language in budget proposals to
facilitate funding from the
republican-controlled Congress which
makes sense the you want certain
language to make it easier to pass these
bills but the story itself is absurd so
what happened to Nancy Pelosi and
typically untrue and hysterical fashion
tweeted out danger all caps Trump admin
is going further down a dangerous and
unamerican path of word and thought
control POTUS has no respect for and has
banned words this is that is truly
unbelievable this is total projection
it's Nancy Pelosi looking in the mirror
and then throwing that on to Donald
Trump now federal officials former Obama
appointees they've shrieked that the
imaginary band was Orwellian and stupid
but it doesn't end there
here is for comment President Trump I
know words I had the best words I have
to but there's no better words than
stupid well said absolutely right
unfortunately though unfortunately there
is no government-wide language
recommendation this is just a directive
regarding certain budget documents the
words in question by the way our fetus
transgender vulnerable science-based
entitlement diversity and evidence-based
and by the way it's too bad that there
are no government-wide language
recommendations here because all of
those words that I just said are empty
slogans their insidious they are
politically correct euphemisms intended
to obscure what they really mean so
let's start with fetus
what does fetus we use fetus to mean
something that isn't a human being so we
can kill it but fetus comes from the
latin for offspring that's all the word
means why not call it an unborn baby why
not call it offspring because the word
fetus allows you to make the baby seem
clinical seem not human seem not alive
we know two things about unborn babies
they're human and they're alive but we
need to wash over that we need to
obscure that language with muddy latin
at words so we don't really know it's a
fetus don't worry we can kill it it's
just a fetus thing with
trans gender now the the modifier trans
means across or beyond right doesn't so
it actually doesn't even make sense in
the way they're using it which is a man
who thinks he's a woman or vice versa or
really wants to be one that isn't even
very precise it would really mean
transcending gender overall going beyond
the categories of gender you know as
might happen in heaven right there is no
male or female in Christ that would be
the transcendence it's funny if you look
in CS Lewis I forget which book of his
it is and it might be a miracles he uses
the word transsexual to refer to how in
heaven we don't we're not lusty and we
don't have sexuality as much that's not
how they use it they use it in because
we don't want to say a man who thinks
he's a woman or a woman who thinks she's
a man or someone suffering from a
psychological condition that makes them
confused about their biological sex
you're just transgender is much easier
voll neural what is vulnerable mean
we're all vulnerable we're all gonna die
no one here gets out of live but what
vulnerable is used to do is take slice
people up into little demographics and
demagogue on them and use them as
political fodder to achieve political
goals how about science base or
evidence-based these two are totally
demagogic political words of course
things are science-based it's used by
the left to say that anyone who doesn't
go along with their crazy plans to
disrupt the economy or to add more
government spending or add more to the
federal deficit they're ignoring science
they seem to forget that you can't
derive an ought from an is you can't
derive
ideas about what we should do from
things that are but they try to lied
over that and so they'll say well this
is science-based the science tells me we
have to raise taxes on everybody and
spend a lot of money that's the science
I know it's not my political point of
view or my ideology so those two is
whether they're used to mean the
opposite of what they really do how
about entitlement what's an entitlement
well one entitlements are bad because
you know it leads to much more economic
or rather a much more federal growth the
entire deficit nation
that is driven by these entitlement
programs Medicare Medicaid and Social
Security but also one isn't entitled to
anything it what it really means is
welfare what it really means is a
handout it means going on the dole but
entitlement that's the way that we
polish it or diversity diversity is
probably the most abused one diversity
should mean different differences right
but the way it's used on campuses here
we say we have diversity and that's why
we need to ban anyone from speaking who
thinks anything a contrary to what we
think in the university orthodoxy or
diversity means race discrimination so
using the university example you might
say we need more diversity and that's
why we need to discriminate against
Asian applicants to universities because
we need diversity you know that's how we
get diversity it's in it never remains
diversity of thought usually what it
means is homogeneity so apparently the
CDC was told to replace you know science
based for example in these documents
with quote the CDC bases its
recommendations on science in
consideration with community standards
and wishes good that is more precise
because science based is so vague
science based is a euphemism what we
really mean by science based especially
what the left means is there is the
aspect of our thought which is
scientific and then we are reading that
through our ideological lens with our
values and our community guidelines or
whatever but science isn't the be-all
and end-all because policy doesn't come
from science we can't just have
technocrats telling us what to do
because men aren't machines there's a
value in the world there's moral weight
there's moral value and so we can use
science in the scientific method as much
as it's useful for and it's very useful
but it isn't sufficient because there's
another component to the world there's
more between heaven and earth that's
dreamed of in our philosophy there's a
there's a metaphysical component to the
world too and we have to take that into
consideration because government because
politics is the relation of people to
one another and government is how we
rule ourselves now this directive is
very limited but it should expand this
is the essential Trump project he
shatters these gooey awful euphemisms
and empty language which is what
political correctness is to get to the
heart of the matter in his own fairy
Trumpy cough FA way watch him expertly
take on the euphemism army
you mean it's not politically correct
and yet everybody is is it I say you
know what give me a different time give
me a different time what else would you
like to say you want me to say that okay
I'll use the word anchor baby excuse me
I'll use the word anchor baby it's
brilliant
this was by the way one of the moments
in the campaign where I started to think
that Donald Trump maybe wasn't just a
complete lunatic ignoramus but maybe he
knows what he's doing because what he's
saying there's anchor baby that's it
paints a picture we know what we meet
we're talking about children who were
born in the United States as a pathway
to citizenship for themselves and their
families and it's very hard to hear what
that reporter is saying but it's
something to the effect of well you
should call them future undocumented
American citizens without the
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah securing the
whole thing and Trump says yeah you know
what I'm gonna stick with anchor baby
I'm gonna stick with the clear language
because that's how I'm going to convince
people about these issues I can't
convince them on your terms on your
crazy abusive language I'm gonna use
reality you terms the better correspond
with reality and that's gonna break your
stranglehold on thought in politics
George Carlin the late comedian talked
about this himself here is we're using
that soft language that language that
takes the life out of life and it is a
function of time it does keep getting
worse
get another example sometime during my
life sometime during my lifetime paper
became bathroom tissue sneakers became
running shoes false teeth became dental
appliances medicine became medication
information became directory assistance
the dumped became the landfill car
crashes became automobile accidents
partly cloudy became partly sunny
motels became motor lodges house
trailers became mobile homes used cars
became previously owned transportation
room service became guest room dining
and constipation became occasional
irregularity by the way this is like
decades ago that he's talking about this
it's gotten so much worse since then but
it's that soft language it takes the
life out of the words it takes what's
convincing out of the words so that the
people who are using this deceptive
language they so that they can deceive
us euphemisms are insidious you know
people often say oh it's just semantics
you're or you're just arguing over
semantics and of course these people
don't know what semantics means
semantics means meaning it's the study
of meaning it's how signs and words and
symbols relate to one another and to
reality this is why they're euphemisms
are so insidious they just proceed by
subtly deceiving us by painting at just
a little bit off an untrue picture of
reality at Christopher Hitchens wrote
for the sake of argument then one must
never let a euphemism or a false
consolation pass uncontested the truth
seldom lies but when it does lie it lies
somewhere in between
it lies it's oh it's just a little off
it's a little we're just gonna push you
slightly a little bit off the mark until
we see a vision of reality that bears no
relation to the truth Winston Churchill
mockingly admit it a quote perhaps we
have been guilty of some terminological
inexactitude he's really saying as we
lied we lied to you but he's mocking
even that accountant concept in that
phrase terminological inexactitude have
you heard that if some lefty went on
television and said terminological
inexactitude you guys would glaze over
and they would get away with the
deception but really it's a lies that PC
and euphemisms like this are lies
language is the medium of our
consciousness it's how we view the world
that's why the left is so insistent on
political correctness on everybody using
their terms and looking at the world on
their terms this is why they're so
insistent over these pronouns virtually
nobody in the country suffers from
psychological gender confusion there are
like five of these people there
not a lot of these people they're
suffering and we can be compassionate to
them but the left has invested countless
funds countless hours energy into a
national campaign to make everyone refer
to men as she and women as e we have why
are we talking about this all the time
doesn't that strike you as a little odd
if this campaign of language we're
really about the vanishingly small
minority of people clinically confused
about their biological sex
wouldn't it be a smaller conversation
but of course not it's part of a larger
project of language to get us to buy
their premises their relativistic
premises their debased and barbaric view
of politics where we're just different
competing interest groups that have no
relation to the truth rather than
civilized people who look at the world
in different ways and debate it and try
to get to reality the truth is arrogant
they try to use reason to get to that
truth here are some other examples this
is unbelievable we no longer have
criminals
according to Obama's Department of
Justice we have justice involved youth
justice involved youth is the
terminology that Obama's DOJ started
using to refer to criminal kids justice
and but now ironically their injustice
involved right they're committing
injustice as they're committing crime
but justice involved we can't even say
that they their offenders they're not
offenders they're just involved you know
I'm involved in justice right pay my
taxes so we have a criminal justice
system I give my legitimacy to a
government I admit to its credibility
that would be involved in justice these
kids are criminals but we have we can't
say that that's that's that's too mean
that gives us the wrong picture
we don't have Wars anymore we just have
overseas contingency operations whatever
it isn't it isn't that so a vivid
doesn't really paint a vivid picture the
the government forcing you to buy a
product from a private company is not a
mandate it's not an unprecedented
mandate it's a quote individual shared
responsibility payment oh go okay in
that case take my money here's my check
the estate tax is used to refer to what
is a death tax what is the death tax
when you die you have to pay a tax
it's unbelievable what that has been
taxed at the corporate level at the
income level of the capital gains level
they but they've got to get you on the
estate there
rather on the death tax by calling it
the estate tax
oh well it's an estate it's no big deal
illegal aliens became undocumented
workers the most absurd version of this
is the dreamers the dreamers these are
illegal aliens this is a clear term but
no they're just dreamers what do you do
you don't like the dreamers you hate
dream we want to kill dreams you monster
women's health now means killing a baby
in the womb that is women's health you
know and you you call up your
grandmother and you say are you doing
gee goes oh well I can still kill babies
in the womb so I have that at least I
have that I don't think so
but that is the euphemism we've even
gone past pro-choice which in itself is
ridiculous if of course it's a choice
the question is what choice is it we
have choices or free people the public
option or the single-payer system that
those are those two euphemisms instead
of government control health care we
have affirmative action instead of
racial discrimination but what is
affirmative action it's giving some
people privileges based on their race
and hurting some people based on their
race so I don't think that there's
anything terribly affirmative for Asian
students who are applying to American
universities what that is by their view
and by any serious view is racial
discrimination but that sounds too icky
mmm terror attacks or man-caused
disasters get gay marriage was lost on
these grounds so the term gay marriage
which then became marriage equality even
a more outrageous euphemism it presumed
a premise so the conservative opposition
to gay marriage is not that gay people
should be discriminated against or not
have certain rights or whatever it's
that marriage does not include same-sex
unions it's just not what marriage is it
would be like it's just a nonsense it's
like saying what's the color of seven it
doesn't have a logical meaning but and
they left knew this so they used the
term the minute they use the term it
totally shifted the debate it skipped
the step of what is marriage what do we
think marriage is in 2017 in our culture
what does what does it mean for society
for individuals for the institution no
it became marriage can include same-sex
unions and will they have those rights
this is where we got to marriage
equality because if it's a question of
rights and equality they have to win you
can't oppose right civil rights and
equality and it totally skipped over too
dishonestly and disingenuously skipped
over the real question which is what is
marriage and if we and if marriage can
include monogamous same-sex unions for
the first time ever why would we exclude
polygamous people are polyamorous
arrangements from marriage that is just
as bigoted by all of that logic
now there's raising revenue we always
have to raise revenue that's
confiscating well through taxation there
is giveaway for the wealthy that means
allowing people to keep more of their
own money that's the giveaway for them
when you let them keep what's theirs
government spending has become
investment doesn't invest in anything
just spends but that's investment global
cooling became global warming which
became the unfold so file climate change
that's hard to beat that climate change
we noticed that it changes we noticed
that there are ups and downs so that's
how they they want an argument they're
obviously obviously we have the holiday
that must not be named you know the
holiday you're getting ready for the
holiday season to welcome that big
holiday man with the big beard and and
really refer back to the incarnate birth
of the holiday guy yeah that's the the
this is what the war on Christmas is
about it's a same argument holds for the
war on Christmas who cares about the
words who cares just semantics right
they care there's a reason they care
even the word liberal became a liberal
we used to be liberals we're liberal now
they're not liberal they're completely
illiberal they're intolerant of anyone
else's views and we should take care to
follow presidents trump president drums
lead on this and avoid euphemistic
language at every turn I know it's
tempting I know I was just in New York
it's very tempting to try to make the
New York Times like us or sophisticated
fancy people like cocktail parties like
us just say who cares about the pronouns
who cares about these silly terms it's
just language they can have it if they
want it who cares the left cares we
should care to the left cares a lot
about it we should not cede to them a
syllable because euphemistic language
gives away whole premises it in turn
concedes the culture ultimately it
concedes our politics and our government
and our Liberty words matter ideas
matter reject PC gobbledygook and only
use the best words folks come on we have
them Lee got the best words let's bring
on our panel to discuss we have Alicia
crass and Amanda presto Giacomo and
all-female panel of deplorable
they had an all-day Lee Weyer panel hey
the best kind
it is the best kind very nice to see you
both two aspects on this story Alicia as
far as the directive itself is there is
there an actual story here is this a
news story or were they just getting
very excited to knock Trump on something
of course they're they're super excited
to not Trump on something I mean Ben has
said it over and over and over again
that being our boss ben shapiro so i'll
say something nice about him now because
it is the christmas season is that he no
christmas christmas season
come on michael no war on christmas here
stuff with that political correctness
it is the christmas season and ben is
right so i'll let him have that he's
right that the mainstream media often
jumps just right to anything that trump
says or anything that anyone within the
administration does and just blows it up
for no reason and sometimes it's hard
that if he ever gets to attend to say
that everything is a ten when some of
the things that he does or maybe a level
four or five but that's not it's this
just too much for them everything they
take and run with that's absolutely
right and you know there i guess there's
this little directive who who really
cares we're talking about budget
proposal documents but they got it
they're gonna run democracy dies in
darkness
now speaking of George Carlin Carlin
said famously when fascism comes to
America it will not be in brown and
black shirts it will not be with Jack
boots it will be Nike sneakers and
smiley shirts smiley smiley and the
smiley is the issue this is the issue
here Amanda when we refer to men who
think they're women or wish very much to
be women as as she or rather as he or
him rather than she or her we look like
jerks is there any way to avoid this
well well that's kind of the whole as
you deconstructed that's kind of the
whole point of them reconstructing
language and using euphemisms and and
being so adamant that we use these
pronouns or whatever the is that task
for that day that's why it's so
important because then the opposite side
like how could you possibly be against
you know equality or diversity or we
know insert buzzword here that's that's
the whole point of the left
deconstructing language so when it comes
to things like gender and how they're
just deconstructing gender it paints the
right to be bigots right they hate trans
people
how dare you not call this grown man and
address you know she or whatever so I
mean this is all by plan and as you said
I think the Conservatives need to really
push back on this deal they're gonna
call you a big anyways they're going to
call you transphobic anyway just say
what is truth like you just have to
stick to the truth because otherwise
they win like we can't kick him see
conceding round as we do so often so
they're gonna call you names anyway and
as we've seen from this past election
speak truth but is there is there any
way not to look like a jerk I'm worried
that we don't look good to a voting
public even though we're saying a true
thing that a man is a man and a woman as
a woman and you can't magically become
one by wishing very much
Alicia you're much nicer than I am is
there any way to like smiley smiley and
look good on this I don't know I mean I
keep reading disturbing things in the
news today about quote-unquote fetuses
and what the UK with their national
health care socialist you know system is
doing and not helping babies born early
and I'm gonna call them baby so the
Trump administration's decision to
change language with the CDC is it's
like fine it's fine by me
I mean if they want us to call them what
they want to be called then maybe they
should show us some respect and call
babies and your neuro actually babies
and not this fetuses and and I just
think it's really disturbing I think
that the the broader it's on one hand
they want to have a hashtag me two women
are always victims movement but then on
the other hand they want to change the
narrative of what the nuclear family is
or the roles that men and women play in
society and I just every single time I
try to look at it every single time I
try to think of like the leftist
perspective it just doesn't make sense
to me and there and I don't know what
their long game is here well you you're
so right on the fetus bit that is so
smart of them they've found a
demographic that doesn't vote you know
Reagan used to say that he notices
everyone who's in favor of abortion has
already been born and those those little
babies don't have a voice in any of this
they they have the least voice of
anybody so if you call them by a
ridiculous euphemism
they won't get angry and vote you out of
office but we do we do run that risk and
I think you're both right I think we
just have to put the truth above all
things and if you state the truth in
good faith and not trying to just be a
jerk about it I think you'll get some
credit for it and people might come
around but you know there is that Bible
it says people hate the truth they're
gonna run away from you so I beware of
what you're doing
caveat emptor okay I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube we have
much more to talk about today we got a
lot of great news out there Pope Francis
is saying things about fake news and
probably damning CNN to hell we've got
the dreamers we've got al franken done
resigning I know you want to see it we
appreciate everybody who already
subscribes you help us keep the lights
on after my two red eyes in three days I
need the cough fa in my cup and you help
fill it up if you are not already
subscribed go to daily wire.com and you
can see the rest of the show it's $10 a
month $100 for an annual membership what
do you get for it you get me you got
Andrew Clavin you get the Ben Shapiro
show yeah yeah yeah I know Michael get
to the good stuff here it is now you
know as well as I do you've been reading
the news we might get a tax reform bill
when that tax reform bill comes down may
God help you you better be ready for
this we know not the time or the hour
when the tax reform bill will be passed
we need that you need that Lapidus tears
tumbler otherwise you're gonna drown and
all those salty salty tears so go to
daily wire.com right now you can have
them hot or cold always salty and
delicious we'll be right back
okay on egregious abuses of language
meant to manipulate our heartstrings and
deceive us it turns out that legalizing
the so-called dreamers the younger
illegal aliens would cost payers 26
billion dollars that's according to the
Congressional Budget Office reporting
Friday that legalizing these 2 million
illegal aliens characterized by Obama's
dreamers would cost twenty five point
nine billion dollars now Alisha
Democrats are so generous with other
people's money that sounds like a
nightmare is there any economic or
political argument to give these people
legal status to give them amnesty I
don't know and I was starting to read
the breakdown of it which is why my head
was down and my eyes were glazed over
when we started that's usually the
reaction I get from women apathy
impatience it wasn't you it was the
numbers and I was trying to break them
down and I was trying to understand them
they're saying that oh it's over a
decade so it's not as big of a deal but
you just mentioned that's 2 million
dreamers I mean I'm not that good at
math but that's way too much money per
immigrant that would become you know
legalized under this potential plan that
of course Democrats are pushing I I
think that there is an argument that tug
at the heartstrings kind of Marco Rubio
Mitt Romney argument that they made of
like some of these people are not here
at the fault of their own so can we give
them a path to citizen
citizenship that kind of enables them to
be a part of the American Dream and but
you know since it wasn't their fault if
they were born here or their parents
brought him legally across the border on
an airplane from Asia you know when they
were like 2 years old right and actually
the the biggest number of these people I
think that are potentially gonna cost us
are the people that come here on a
travel or a student visa and then just
ride it out it isn't these dreamers so
that's a separate part of immigration
that we have to take care of but I just
that is a lot of money to cover two
million people and I don't know what
argument the Democrats can make that to
say well they're gonna end up paying
this back to society because that's a
lot of responsibility for those two
million dreamers to have on their own
backs I mean couldn't we send them to
like Harvard Law School PhD buy them a
house in a car for all that money where
they spending all this money oh I
thought you were suggesting Ivy League's
and I mean everyone
ivy-league I can't stand well we
certainly shouldn't send them there we
I'm all for saying they can stay if they
promise to vote Republican but that will
not be achieved because there's lots of
Republicans as we saw aka Alabama that
I'm not okay with I mean I'm all for
people staying that are going to
contribute to the fundamentals of of you
know what our Constitution stands for
what the Bill of Rights stands for and
gonna you know provide for themselves
and for their family and I just this is
one of those areas that when you get in
the weeds and when you get in the
numbers it is kind of hard to have a
very clear cut and dry example but the
numbers that they're coming up with out
of this report are just astonishing and
it's way too much I know and you're
right on Alabama it was awful when those
Republicans stayed home and gave it to
Doug Johnson it was awful
Amanda you know Nana there has long been
a pro-immigration strain in the GOP
that's what Alicia's talking about that
Mitt Romney thing it's even in the
conservative movement though I mean
there are plenty of good arguments for
immigration in particularly from
immigration from Latin America they work
hard and they go to church so maybe we
should adjust to them you know you
should take a page or two out of their
book but is that now finished is that
open borders you know come in and all
that really matters is GDP and who cares
what happens to political institutions
if we don't bring these people over and
Americanize them quickly enough is that
over and if so what killed it I think
this past election shows that Pete and
this is a cross I would say political
parties as well people want a secure
sovereign nation they don't want people
flowing through this country we saw that
I mean Donald Trump's number one
platform was immigration and it wasn't
just illegal immigration it was that too
but people want a strong sovereign
country and you know I just I don't see
how these dreamers or chain migration or
any of these things are wins for the
left I mean their whole goal of course
is to bring over these these dreamers or
these illegals and give amnesty because
then they will vote a certain way and
that 80 percent
for democrat yeah 100% so that's their
incentive but the American people don't
want that like I said we saw that in the
election so I don't see how it's
especially with these dreamers I don't
understand how we're just gonna I just I
don't think this makes any political
sense so they're gonna contribute I
think it was estimated in 900 million
dollars but you know both are gonna cost
us 20 26 or 29 billion dollars and
that's just them right we have like I
think it's estimated 12 million illegals
in the country now and then with chain
migration if we don't get that clamp
down on they're gonna bring those two
million dreamers are gonna bring over
800,000 other family members so this
just compounds in compounds we're
already in massive debt I just don't see
how this is politically viable and I
think the election showed that so we
need to actually focus on the border
focus on the illegals already half here
and then dreamers should be like last
and we can maybe you know use that as
you know as a collateral to get what we
want on the right but I just I don't see
how it's a politically advantageous
thing to do for the Republicans well
it's funny because well Barack Obama and
the left and Democrats were advocating
spending twenty six billion dollars
presumably giving these particular
illegal aliens gold-plated Lamborghinis
he ended Barack Obama ended the wet foot
dry foot policy that allowed Cubans who
were fleeing Cuban slavery to have legal
status in America and it is I can't help
but notice that one of those immigrants
vote for Democrats and those Cubans are
pretty reliably Republican what a
coincidence huh he was even attacked by
some immigration activists right here in
California in Los Angeles he had
protesters standing up during speeches
and up in the Bay Area as well he had
Asian protesters immigrant protesters
stand up certain during some of his
speeches because it was kind of the do
as I say not as I do
it was one of those campaign promises
that he had made about similar to I'm
gonna close down Gitmo he had made
promises to immigrants and to dreamers
and toward the end of his second term
his own base started to get frustrated
with him when they realized he wasn't
gonna keep those promises that he had
made yeah it's very hard and and get
most still open that's okay
not so bad having a four lefty president
is sometimes okay if he's also
incompetent Pope Francis came out
swinging against fake news on Saturday
he said presumably an Italian in his
very nice
Pope Francis way we must not fall prey
to the sins of communication
disinformation that is giving just one
side of the argument slander which is
sensationalistic or defamation looking
for outdated and old things and bringing
them to light today interesting in the
wake of me to Amanda has the Holy Father
just condemned CNN to hell
it looks like it I mean he's putting his
foot down on fake news and and the
number one people disseminating fake
news happens to be CNN in Washington
Post not far behind but CNN is the main
purveyor yeah yeah definitely I mean I
know I know Pope Francis leans left on
some things I mean not unlike Church
doctoring but but like just like climate
change and things like that but but this
did seem like a slap in the face to the
the mainstream media so it's very
welcome actually it's a good sorry go
ahead
I think Pope Francis was victims of fake
news himself so I think he's a little he
might be to the left I don't think
anyone would deny that but if you
compare the number of things he has said
with the number of things that the
mainstream media say that he has said
they're very different lists now so what
do you make of the Pope's argument is he
essentially because it cuts both ways it
hits CNN but it also hits those of us
who have points of views as well is he
essentially saying that public relations
is inherently sinful that communications
for a campaign or a company you should
have thought that like reading hits to
his detailed statement and I was like oh
snap like I guess depending on what side
of the aisle you are your candidate is
screwed in the Pope thinks that you're
spewing disinformation or trying to make
things look better than they are
but I think to actually journalists as a
whole there's probably I can count on
one hand the journalist that I actually
respect one of them would be Amy Parnes
who wrote that book about the fallout of
Hillary Clinton's campaign and how from
the inside she saw it all going to
threads to shreds and part of the reason
I trust her is that she does not talk
about her political
she's not even registered to vote and so
reading the Pope's quote I think you
could potentially construe it as a word
commentary politics and he's kind of
pooh-poohing on us but then who could
also read it as an encouragement to true
journalists to go out and do their
journalistic duty which is to get to the
truth which is to get to the bottom line
and to not offer their political opinion
or their side - it should truly be to
steal a Fox News of grace fair and
balanced but I think it could apply to
you know the Fox News is of the world
and also the cnn's of the world here and
we're very we always drink also is that
you're like favorite is this your
favorite news story of the week it's
like your Pope and fake news like in the
things it really is like a Christmas
present what made me feel very good
because obviously I always try to order
this show to be very balanced give both
sides equal weight because that's what
we do here we I will say there are at
least more serious journalists at the
panel of deplorable z-- than CNN or the
New York Times or The Washington Post so
maybe that'll get me just like two
thousand years in purgatory instead of
you know going straight to hell cigars
like what is the Catholic Church well
the body is a temple in the temple needs
incense GH estrogen southern Catholic
Church is a thick steak it's like a
thick steak a glass of red wine and a
good cigar and I believe him and you
know even if the Pope doesn't watch the
Michael Nolt show perhaps he does but
even if he doesn't you know the Pope is
only infallible when he is infallible
that's not all the time so who knows if
he's speaking ex cathedra I don't think
so let's move on to senators who are now
calling on Al Franken not to resign
that's so funny who could have predicted
this Oh me Joe Manchin Pat Leahy both
think he should not have resigned
Manchin said what they did to Nell was
atrocious the Democrats they groped him
during photo ops no that's not what he
said said I hope they have enough guts
and enough conscience and enough heart
to say al we made a mistake asking you
prematurely to leave you're good enough
you're smart enough and gosh darn er
people like you he presumably added
later pat leahy added I think we acted
prematurely before we had all the facts
amber Phillips writes today in
Washington Post could Al Franken
unreason sure of course he could because
he hasn't resigned yet I knew it I told
you when it happened I
knew it when I heard this clip today I
am announcing that in the coming weeks I
will be resigning as a member of the
United States Senate you know I I am
announcing to you at some point
something will change at some point I
brave bold stay some point Ben Shapiro
is gonna finally fire you who's that
yeah that's like a hundred percent drew
the question is when you know Alicia was
the fix in this whole time was this
always a fake resignation mix was in I
think and I think that it had all had to
do with Alabama that they wanted to set
it up as they were holier-than-thou they
were the righteous people they're the
ones who stand for women and all that
jazz that they like to stout all the
time but now that their guy won in
Alabama they're gonna be like dang it
the the GOP the voters in Alabama didn't
fall for our racist southern bigoted you
know Pro child molester vote thing and
so now we have to make sure that we can
maintain this vote in the Senate and
keep good a while in here I'm really
disappointed I mean I know that mansion
has addy after his name but on some
things he votes pretty you know more
independently than the Democratic Party
he could be doing it to save his own
seat but I'm really disappointed in him
for this I thought that he was
potentially a better human being than
that well you know Andrew Klavan does
describe these guys accurately as the
four city politicians right this is the
all-star league of politicians and so
joe Manchin's good on gun control
why is he good on gun control cuz he's
from West Virginia if he lived in New
York he might have a different position
I'd be more schumer like yeah right
they're very good at being politicians
and that's what you're seeing here from
Joe Manchin I I mean he's better than
Nancy Pelosi certainly but then again
Nancy Pelosi doesn't live in West
Virginia Amanda what should Republicans
be hoping for here with Al Franken
should we be encouraging him to resign
and setting this precedent that if
anyone accuses you years later of
getting a little handsy with no real
possible evidence that you can just
resign
obviously there was that photo of him
getting weird at the USO tour
but a lot of these allegations are
totally unverifiable they're saying well
he slipped a hand and was never on
camera and yada yada yada should we be
hoping for that or do we want Franken to
stay so that we can hang it around
Democrats necks well not not to hang
around their necks but I don't I don't
think you should go because I don't
think like you said none of these
allegations were fully proven I know
there was that picture but if I mean if
you look at the well I'm not I'm not
going to sit here and defend al franken
like that picture was grow she was
sleeping I'm not gonna defend that but a
lot of these other allegations were not
you know he denied them and they weren't
proved I mean that so again like we have
to be really careful to just take an
accusation and then you know ruin
someone's life or ruin someone's career
like I said before we've seen this on
college campuses and it's really really
bad stuff so let's think of due process
and not just like you know crush anyone
who has an allegation especially when
it's a you know 20 or 40 years ago like
we saw before and then also one another
point is that so I think without Franken
they were they were just you know having
him hang on there and then we're gonna
see like as you said Michael that they
were gonna if for more one you know they
could probably find a way to get him
back in there but but also I think it's
they're realizing it's taking him so
long that the act that this whole thing
was set up to go after Trump like they
re bringing up these meet these
allegations against President Trump that
we all heard during the election he this
is already been litigated this is
already been lit again like they had
megyn kelly last week you know trying to
relitigate this she had all these
accusers on nobody cared nobody watched
we already knew this yeah and I mean
more information about Lisa bloom that
attorney and she apparently was
procuring money for women who were
coming forward and saying that President
Trump accused most sexual assault we
start to harassment that's troublesome
we already knew it but there it isn't in
a report from the hill and that's the
hill that's not from you know some
right-wing site how much is she offering
not because you know the blank book
money is kind of running out and
to say a lot of things I have the best
folks no you're you're absolutely right
there is this mania there is this
hysteria that's going on where if
someone's career and life can be ruined
because someone said something happened
40 years ago clearly we've reached a
point beyond justice we've reached a
point beyond due process but there's
another consideration for why we should
keep Franken which is that it's totally
cost-free for Democrats to bump him it
actually helps them because there's a
Democrat governor of Minnesota a
Democrat will likely replace him even at
the next election so it doesn't really
matter where as Al Franken House damaged
goods keep him in there that is
absolutely fine I'm not gonna let
Democrats get a free pass when it
doesn't matter
give me Bob Menendez then we'll talk
give me Menendez okay ladies thank you
for being here from the daily wire
Amanda Prestage giacomo Alicia Krause
that is our whole show today
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show come back tomorrow we'll do
it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017